[Música]
hablamos de economía en directo américa
de france 24 y luis méndez zúrich de
nuevo con nosotros son vamos a iniciar
entonces en china porque algunas
empresas están siendo impactadas vidas
por los efectos del cambio climático así
es raúl en el suroeste de la nación
algunas fábricas cerraron debido a la
sequía que afecta esa zona del país y
provocó una reducción en los niveles de
los principales embalses los embalses
son utilizados para generar energía
hidroeléctrica y se agotaron de acuerdo
con informes de prensa que recoge la
publicación catarí al yazira provocaron
que las empresas ubicadas en la
provincia de sichuan entre las que se
encuentran fabricantes de paneles
solares cemento y nuria cerraran o
redujeran la producción ante la orden de
racionar la energía por al menos cinco
días la situación se sumó a las
tensiones económicas que afectan al país
en parte por los nuevos bloqueos en la
nación como consecuencia de los brotes
de kobe 19 ante este panorama la
economía creció sólo un 25 por ciento
respecto al año pasado en la primera
mitad del año 2022 esto es menos de la
mitad de la meta anual
que está registrada en 55 % y nos vamos
hasta el reino unido- list porque se
registró el mayor dato de inflación en
40 años así que si de acuerdo con lo
publicado por la oficina de estadísticas
nacionales la inflación en ese país
registró un alza de tasa anual de 0.7
puntos porcentuales durante el mes de
julio para ubicarse en 10.1 por ciento y
deja atrás el 9,4 por ciento que fue
registrado en el pasado mes de junio con
ellos superan las estimaciones de los
analistas que pronosticaban un aumento
del ipc de 98 % de acuerdo con la
oficina nacional de estadísticas la
mayor responsabilidad de este aumento
recae en los altos precios de los
alimentos que subieron un 23 % entre
junio y julio para ubicarse en 12 7% en
el séptimo mes del año a tasa anual el
canciller t hacienda de reino unido está
en jagüey ha expresado en varias
ocasiones que controlar la inflación es
su prioridad tras conocerse los datos de
inflación reveló que están tomando
medidas a través de una política
monetaria fuerte e independiente
decisiones fiscales y gasto responsables
también con reformas para impulsar la
productividad y el crecimiento por el
momento no ha expresado una política
clara para solventar en líneas generales
la situación pero la nación ha dispuesto
un paquete de ayuda por un valor de 37
mil millones de libras esterlinas que
entre otras cosas otorgará 400 libras a
los de menos recursos para descuentos en
las facturas de energía precisamente el
aumento de los precios de energía ha
sido la mayor preocupación para las
autoridades por lo que los
parlamentarios han propuesto un plan
para frenar el precio especialmente en
los meses de invierno que están por
venir escuchemos qué fue lo que dijo el
líder de los laboristas sobre este plan
aus came polly founder nuestro plan está
completamente financiado depende un
impuesto sobre las ganancias inesperadas
de las compañías de petróleo y gas para
mantener ese precio congelado estos
países
permitimos que las compañías sigan
haciendo enormes ganancias mientras que
millones de hogares están luchando o
hacemos algo al respecto which is
something avance seguimos hablándoles
por supuesto de datos económicos como
estuve el crecimiento de la zona euro
durante el segundo trimestre fue
bastante bien la zona euro en su
crecimiento durante el segundo cuarto
del presente año de acuerdo con la
estimación preliminar de la eurostat la
oficina de estadísticas de la unión
europea el producto interno bruto de la
eurozona creció un 0,6 por ciento es
decir una décima de punto porcentual por
debajo de las estimaciones y registró un
crecimiento similar en la unión europea
recordemos que la eurozona está formada
por aquellos países que adoptaron al
euro como moneda de curso legal en
comparación con el primer trimestre de
crecimiento fue de 0,1 por ciento para
el bloque
y de 0,2 por ciento en la eurozona a
nivel anual el producto interno bruto en
la zona euro aumentó un 3,9 por ciento
al tiempo que en la unión europea fue de
4% ya tomando en cuenta los datos de
empleo el porcentaje de ocupados se
incrementó en 0 3% durante el primer
trimestre solamente en la zona euro y
pasamos a rusia porque ministerio de
economía generó calma en los mercados y
también en su población y es que esta
institución indicó que el país
registrará una contracción menor a la
esperada y que ésta no será tan alta
como se había pronosticado hace unos
tres meses atrás las palabras sugieren
que la economía está lidiando con las
sanciones de mejor manera que lo tomaba
en cuenta inicialmente la economía rusa
se está viendo afectada por una recesión
después de que moscú envió fuerzas
armadas a ucrania el pasado 24 de
febrero el producto interno bruto ruso
se contraen as de acuerdo a lo dicho por
el ministerio un 4,2 por ciento este año
y los ingresos reales disponibles caerán
un 28 por ciento en comparación con las
caídas pronosticadas de 78 de 6 a 8 %
respectivamente de hace 3 meses el
ministerio ahora ve una inflación de fin
de año de un 13 4% y un desempleo que
está ubicándose en un 48 por ciento si
lo comparamos con los pronósticos
anteriores de 17.5 por ciento y de 67
por ciento en estos datos
respectivamente hablamos ahora de
applebee's porque esta compañía estaría
trasladando parte de su producción a
vietnam así de raúl se desprende un
informe publicado por el periódico
concede jamón y kate y sawyer el texto
dado a conocer este miércoles y que es
citado por otros medios de comunicación
revela que los proveedores de japón
están en conversaciones para producir el
papel boat y el equipos macbook en
vietnam por primera vez el medio cita a
personas familiarizadas con las
conversaciones de hecho agrega que el
look ser precisión inducida de china y
el ensamblador de iphone taiwanés
foxconn comenzaron la producción de
pruebas de apple watch en el norte de
vietnam o por ha estado trasladando
algunos elementos de la producción de
iphone de china a otros mercados entre
ellos
donde se fabrica el iphone 13 de este
este año india el segundo mercado de
teléfonos inteligentes más grande del
mundo y países como méjico y vietnam se
están volviendo cada vez más importantes
para los fabricantes que suministran
marcas estadounidenses y que intentan
diversificar la producción más allá de
china indicadores económicos las
acciones están cerraron mixtas este
miércoles en los principales mercados
asiáticos que esperaban fuertes señales
de cambios sobre todo en las economías
de eeuu y china después de los últimos
resultados en asia registraron ganancia
a los mercados de japón y también el de
hong kong al tiempo que kospi de corea
del sur revirtió ganancias de después de
un comienzo positivo probablemente por
las tomas de ganancia entre las
principales acciones entre las grandes
pérdidas del mercado está la de hyundai
motors con 38 por ciento los analistas
también advierten sobre riesgos
importantes como el aumento del caso de
kobe 19 en algunos países de asia y
preocupaciones sobre la inflación
mundial el mercado europeo sigue en
estos momentos ya cercano su cierre
a la baja cifra el día tiene que ver en
este caso con los
62,4 millones de pasajeros que se estima
que viajen por el aeropuerto de dubai
este año esto representa un 7 por ciento
más que el pronóstico realizado por las
autoridades de ese terminal aéreo en los
meses recientes se duplica la cantidad
de pasajeros durante la primera mitad
louis como siempre gracias por toda la
información económica mañana con más
economía pasamos a saludar a juegos
mundiales que nos tiene todas las
noticias deportivas una de última hora
por cierto